foreign  [Music]  alone together for a whole weekend don't  forget to unload the dishwasher  I can teach you lots of things little  brothers I call it my rod Rick rolls  don't you mean roderick's rules Roger  curl number one no apostrophes or any  other nerd stuff  I loaded diaper one two three four  whoa it's party time  so what's rule number two you only get  one roll a week that's project rule  number two that's not fair rule number  three life's not fair and now you made  me break rule number two uh  Roger could take me under his wing been  teaching me a bunch of stuff what kind  of stuff  I've got a potential little bro  [Music]  mean you're gonna have our battles  that but when the chips are down don't  let him get away I'm gonna have your  back and you better have mine  you look like you wet yourself  [Music]  it's nasty cause we are  Rider Girl number 10 always go out in a  blaze of glory Susan  see I can't unsee that  [Music]  thank you  [Music]